I randomly tweeted just casually about  Franklin and bash cuz Franklin and bash  I love ya are you aware that there's an  ongoing fan theory that or like the  better better call Saul ends with Kim  Wexler just changing her name to Ellen  and moving to moving to become an  assistant DA in another city  what tell oh I love it no I was not  aware of that that's hysterical um yeah  she has uh there's some similarities I  feel like there's more differences than  similarities but there's definitely a  very terse way of speaking if Kim was  trying to be witty with how terse and  clip she speaks then she would be going  towards um I feel like Ellen was very  aware of having zingers um and there's  no way on swatello would sit as silently  as Kim does through like eight pages of  in her mind  idiots blabbing on and she's just  waiting to go in for the kill um yeah  that's funny in some ways Ellen and  Ellen seem so but not but actually I  feel like Ellen has a lot less restraint  than Kim West